how many times have you watched the
original Fast and Furious
I've watched it at least 100 times
um
I love the franchise right so it's one
of my top three favorite movies Fast and
Furious Terminator 2 and Lion King those
are my three favorite movies
um
I love everything about car culture it's
one of those things where everyone
that's kind of late 20s 30s 40s we all
watch Fast and the Furious We all loved
it at its time and it inspired a whole
generation of car lovers so
Fast and Furious is a remake kind of of
Point Break uh Point Break from with
Keanu Reeves and stuff and it follows
the same kind of story except it's
centered around street racing
and those cars today the eclipse Supra
RX7 those are so iconic in today's world
and I don't think they realized when
they created the film that it would turn
into a billion dollar 10 movie franchise
but
Fast and Furious for any car lover is
probably one of the greatest
franchises for car lovers ever to exist
because you have muscle cars you have
JDM Cars you have Euro Cars you have
exotic cars you have everything and you
know Fast and Furious one is a
masterpiece faster too fast to Furious
is so enjoyable Tokyo Drift has some of
the best car sequences and it was shot
you know and the whole theme takes place
in in Tokyo and then you have four five
six seven eight nine
that slowly morphs into I guess like the
hero Espionage spy but still have some
cars in there
um that's what led me to make four
Amigos was after about fast and the
furious five they kind of started
steering towards towards International
spies and kind of left the tuna cars
alone
and I was like okay well there's a niche
and there's a space
that is neglected and alienated and I
feel like I can help fill that void so
hopefully by this film being successful
because I already wrote the sequel It's
a three film series the sequel is done
and then I know where the third film's
going that it leads to a sequel but it
also leads to other filmmakers to make
more tuner Centric films because if I'm
able to do that and say okay hey guys we
don't all have to go to space or we
don't have to all have you know these
out of these world events take place
within the tuner car space we can create
grounded tuner car movies
um then if I can do it you can do it too
and I would love to watch your film as
well because we all have this common
love of cars so if I open that door and
people start busting through the the
front of the house and all of a sudden
next year there's five tuner movies I
would absolutely be thrilled and
delighted because now you have more
films that interest you as a tuner lover
right it's the same as Like Loving
rom-coms or action films or sci-fi space
films the more the merrier it's the same
thing when you think about movies and
remakes and sequels and prequels like I
love it because it doesn't take away
from whatever that original was that was
your Masterpiece it's just an expansion
on that story
what is tuner culture
tuner culture is a beautiful culture
it's a culture of males females
different races ethnicities it doesn't
matter they all come together for the
love of their cars and it doesn't matter
if it's JDM
usdm or udm Euro exotic Honda Civics uh
by you expressing yourself through your
car your car almost becomes an avatar
of who you are it becomes almost like a
robot right it's an extension of you and
your soul that's why there's so much
color there's so much depth
um there's so many different styles of
builds you have all motor builds stance
builds body kits track builds you have
daily cars like I personally drive a
gr86 which is a Toyota grd6
it's the second generation of a BRZ GT86
and
I bought that because it's lightweight
rear-wheel drive and it has adequate
power but tuner culture
they like to Tinker with everything
sometimes you'll have anime decals
you'll have suspension with wheels
you'll have ah let me throw on a turbo
kit or let me throw on a supercharger
kit let me add a chameleon wrap with
some 20 inch wheels with low profile
tires let me do the interior so there's
so many different ways that tuner
culture Embraces cars
that
there's a high love there for everyone
that's why places like um cars and
coffee caffeine and octane car meets on
Tuesday nights
it's such a big thing because you're
Gathering right it's something like the
what the internet brought for people
there's people that are like you that
have the same interests as you and if
you think of your childhood
and I know for my childhood my best
friends we had one thing in common and
that was cars
my best friend had an MX6 with a klze
swap that I later bought from him I had
an MX3 at a time and then at the time
and then I bought a CRX my other friend
had a Subaru WRX with a STI
um swap my other friend had like a Ford
Escort
but we all loved cars so after school
we'd go meet up with the cars and just
have fun right
cars
are popular and have such a large
following and fan base
because they're introduced to you as
your freedom vehicle when you first get
your license at 16.
and then they're an extension of Who You
Are
when it comes to a expression
you're able to show what you have inside
on your vehicle and be like yeah this is
what I drive this is my whip
so that's why it's so important
what makes the Fast and Furious
franchise so successful
so we've grown with these characters
we've grown with these characters for
now 20 years
from the first fast and the furious to
Fast and Furious now 10. you know
all of us still feel
like the passing of Paul Walker like to
this day like we all know like there was
his memorial just took place
um
we've grown with Vin Diesel
Tyrese
ludicrous like we've grown with these
characters
and
you have two audiences now you have the
tuna culture that will always support
fast and furious because there's not
many other options out there for car
films like if you think of rom-coms or
anything else there's plenty of films
but for some reason with tuner films
there just aren't many no one else wants
to tackle it for some odd reason
um and then they have action
so now you took the formula of back in
the day where action films with Arnold
Schwarzenegger and and
um uh Jean-Claude Van Damme and you know
Predator you take that and then now you
add tuner cars and you combine them
you have a successful recipe and I think
the last five films did like a billion
at the box office or something like that
you're gonna win because even if
someone's not into tuner cars they're
into the action
but then the tuner car which is a
multi-billion dollar industry
they want to see the cars too if only
now with the later films only if it's
for a little bit
you still want to see the NSX or the the
Supra on a big iMac screen or in 4k done
at the highest level
how does the Fast and Furious rank
in all-time franchises do you know
so I don't know as far as hard numbers
but I know that for me
it's up there with
maybe even surpassed it
Terminator
um
it's up there with Star Wars it's
definitely that they were Star Wars
um I can't really say Marvel because
Marvel has like 50 films with characters
that have spanded 50 to 100 years that
have like really deep following that
rooted from comic books and I don't
think anything compares to Marvel right
now as far as franchises but I would put
it up there even though James Bond has a
longer list of films I would put it up
there with with really any franchise and
what I base
films
off of and I know this this might be
different for a lot of people
are two things
enjoyability and can you re-watch it
if you have a masterpiece that you watch
sonically it's amazing visually it's
stunning editing everything about it the
film is absolutely brilliant
but when you get done watching it and
you've got the climax of it you got the
story and you never watch it again
that that kind of sucks not that the
film sucks but that kind of sucks that
now because you've seen the Crux of it
you're like okay I don't know I don't
really need to watch it again I've seen
it right
for me something like a Fast and the
Furious
Marvel films
Star Wars alien Terminator
you can re-watch those films
and enjoy them it's like Christmas films
during Christmas you can re-watch them
and enjoy them and I'd rather have a
re-watchable film that brings enjoyment
whether you watch it yearly or during
specific events
because now that film's living with you
it's growing with you you're taking it
along with you so fast and furious
definitely has that because even if
you're only into the cars
you're able to re-watch it over and over
and over if you love cars
um and I think that's a rewatchability
and enjoyment are two major things that
I think people Overlook when they judge
movies
if you judge a movie based on
and you take those things out and let's
say you have something that wins
Sundance right it's like oh it wants
Sundance It's A Beautiful film
but let's say it doesn't do well
financially and not to say everything
has to do well financially but in a
business it has to do well financially
or the whole ship sinks
but you have a beautiful film that went
Sundance but it doesn't sell to a
distributor and it doesn't get out to an
audience or let's say it does get out to
an audience but they don't think it's
that beautiful because they're not a
cinephile they like movies that they can
turn their brain off a little bit and
just enjoy
and then they live with that film for
years and years to come
what do you think has more of an impact
it's like that Masterpiece that one
Sundance that everyone in the industry
claims is the most beautiful film that
year
or that fast and furious film or Star
Wars film or Marvel film that you can
just enjoy and love and watch for your
kids and just have a good time and then
you can do the same thing with that same
film next year
which one has a greater impact
I think the film that has rewatchability
and you can enjoy
and you wanted to make your own version
yes I wanted to make my own version as
much as I could
and I feel like we accomplished that
it's a it's a tuner film set in Atlanta
you have a an enormous collection of
cars
you have car sequences that are extended
and longer for the car audience than it
should have been for example if you're
going to cut to the scene maybe you have
one two three car shots and then you go
into the scene I would take that and
turn that into 30 shots of cars and then
go into the scene
um
in hindsight right as you get better and
evolve you look at your past projects
and you're like man I wish I could have
done this better or oh I could have did
that better
but again it goes back to the filmmaker
you have to create
in that time and space that you're in
and do the best that you can can do in
that time with what you have
because if you don't then maybe the
opportunity and the timing leaves you
and you may not ever be able to create
it again because you waited to try and
make it perfect like there's certain
shots where it would have been nice to
have a a huge gimbal attached to a truck
and then you get those shots because the
shots would have been super steady
compared to a little more shakier
because you don't have the right gimbal
but that's the gimbal that you have for
that shot
so you use it and then you capture what
you capture
if you wait to procure that truck
what happens if you're not able to
procure that truck you're not able to
procure that gimbal something falls
through this actor that you shot all
these scenes with no longer can shoot
something else happens because life
happens
so when that energy consumes you and it
inspires you to do something you got to
act in that moment because the moment
you second guess you start giving
yourself excuses on not doing it and a
lot of times you won't do it if you
don't act in that moment and it's sort
of like driving as well you can't really
you got to just kind of if you're too
focused on being scared of something or
whatever you could actually end up
hurting yourself 100 percent
how many cars did you have and four
Amigos
man a lot
so we
s2000s
VW VOC what Volkswagen the Jettas uh NSX
supercharged brz's Chargers Porsches
um
of course STIs we had uh I don't think
we had a Corvette in this film uh but we
had an NSX racing down the freeway
uh Mustangs gt350s 90 Supras 2020 uh one
Supras Mark Mark IV Mark V
um we you name it we've had it and the
only legendary really car in that list
that we kind of didn't have with within
the tuner space
uh was an RX7
so I I couldn't I couldn't procure that
and I wanted to but we had probably a
good
I want to say 40 cars
we had Lamborghinis a Lotus uh lotuses
evoras uh
Aston Martin's we've had a little bit of
everything yeah
and how did you get these cars again you
you put out calls yeah so for months I
knew that we were going to film on a
specific date so about three four months
in advance
I would go to every car meet every big
car meets small car meet and I would get
emails and I would get contacts and this
goes back to me selling food in Hawaii
right I would just hustle and you'd have
people say no I'm not interested or
you're a weirdo or whatever and I would
approach everybody hey man I'm gonna
shoot this this film can I get your
contact you might want to be in it and I
would just compile this list over months
and then when it came time to shoot it
was like hey guys I'm shooting this is
what I'm kind of looking for do you have
it do you have it and because the car
community and car culture they're so
loving
they were able to embrace me and help
guide me uh and help me bring this film
to life
so yeah so so some of them you gave them
the call time and they showed up and
they showed up and uh a lot of the cars
in the movie are real cars a lot of the
actors in the movie with the cars it's
their car oh cool and you know I I was
able to add them to the film and let
them be a part of film history uh so it
was nice and and you know in the sequel
if I get if I get to the opportunity to
make the sequel it Dives deeper into
tuner cars and it's one of those things
where
I just kind of wanted to give back to a
culture that gave me so much joy and
because I realized that there was a gap
there and we didn't have many tuner
films to watch
I created something for them to watch
where can we see it so four Amigos now
it's on Amazon Prime uh it's on tivot so
you can rent it I think uh for 4.99 or
3.99
um and then in a couple months it will
be on 2B TV great yeah excellent